je m'appelle gabor szilasi ga et om
gabor szilasi est un des photographes
que plus importants du québec et c'est
aussi un homme éminemment sympathique
j'ai étudié en photo qui je tombais sur
ces photos à gabor ça a été
l'illumination totale parce que je
retrouvais dans ses photos tout l'est m
la poésie mais aussi l'humour le respect
je crois qu'il y avait ça dans ses
portraits beaucoup durant quatre ans la
réalisatrice jouanny lafreniere
accompagné gabor aujourd'hui âgé de 93
ans pour qu'il lui raconte sa vie et son
destin exceptionnel je suis arrivé à
québec avec mon père est arrivé comme
une réfugiée dans les années cinquante
du communisme
comme l'a7 à
son arrivée au québec il a parcouru la
belle province pour la photographie pour
le festifilm du québec si c'était
vraiment le québec aux portes de la
modernité c'est comme si avoir capté
cette transformation le qui se faisait
doucement une collection de photos riche
et précieuse qui raconte de manière
incomparable un pan de notre histoire
oui j'adore déjà durement la
photographie c'était une bonne façon de
rencontrer les gens durant des décennies
il a photographié de grands artistes
aussi bien que des quidams avec
sensibilité humour et respect j'ai une
approche plus optimiste et positive de
la vie
je crois que les gens en général sont
bons meilleurs des méchants aussi
cabaret né en 1928 donc
connu la deuxième guerre mondiale et
avait quand même des choses que j'ai
découverte aussi au fils de
de nos rencontres
puis que je trouve qu'ils étaient
importants
à aborder je pense que la résilience que
chez cet homme le si on comprend
pourquoi y est passé on comprend aussi
cette résilience là ils nous ont attrapé
alors frontières le film d'abord parle
d'exil d'amour et d'amitié avec force et
sensibilité
dans l'objectif de gabor et dans celui
de joannie les gens sont beaux à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur
si nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]